hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots video game chatroo every tuesday
at 2 p.m pacific right here on
gamespot.com a little bit late today
apologies for that we had some technical
difficulties nothing to do with any
other website that's in this building at
all
but we're here we're good and we're here
to talk about video games video games i
love them actual video games uh it was
good to talk about the division last
week we're starting to get access to
games 2016 and they're starting to come
out as well uh the witness i played a
bunch of it today looking forward to
talking to you michael better who
reviewed it for gamespot.com and a
little bit we're also going to talk to
you about far cry primal which you've
played a couple of hours of yeah four
hours four hours okay that's pretty
sweet um and also we're going to talk
about uh a bunch of other sort of mini
bits of news that happened uh kj and
ifune game got delayed who knew and uh
five nights at freddy's party has also
been pulled uh off of steam so lots to
talk about this week uh thank you so
much for joining us on gamespot.com or
twitch.tv forward slash gamespot i'll be
checking in on the chat as well if you
have any questions at all but any of the
topics we have on today's show please
feel free and to say them to me at danny
o'dwyer on both of those chats all right
first of all gentlemen we talked about
the division last week we had a great
little chinwag about how that game's
turning out and
and the the beta which is which is
starting imminently as well
but an interesting thing happened we
went to the statistics meeting on a
monday morning as we do here at gamespot
and for some reason views on ghost recon
wildlands had just like spiked last week
uh
it kind of got us asking the question uh
was the gameplay that we were sort of
hoping for for the division the sort of
this this partying up open world
sprawling sort of you know find your own
adventure uh uh experience was that
actually more of what's going on in
ghost recon wildlands
than in the
division uh so we saw wildlands in at e3
last year uh i'm kind of just interested
in your guy's perspective on what
wildlands is because a lot of this has
to do with like
perception like what is the game peter
to you what do you think goals ghost
recon wildlands is and what do you think
the division is is it hard for you to
like devise which is which because both
ubisoft games both are third-person
shooters like what in your head
gameplay-wise how do they
seem different at this stage excellent
it's hard for me to offer too much
because i haven't really thought about
that game a lot since even right but
reading a bit about it uh before the
show this morning i mean it sounds like
it's a much more
it's a game that that focuses on the
tactical aspect of teamwork and you know
in solving an issue and from what i
understand about the division that's not
so much the case like there obviously is
some tactical considerations at hand but
it's also um
i don't know how to characterize but it
sounds like uh there is maybe more
substance to the tactical side of a game
right like wildland yeah because what
we've sort of seen from the division uh
since they've been showing a lot of
gameplay is that it's quite it's quite
wave based it seems like you're yeah
it's a cover shooter yeah
yeah we're looking at wildlands here
which is a game uh set in bolivia you're
sort of a set of u.s uh undercover
agents as the ghosts tend to be who are
going in to kill a bunch of cartels
ubisoft paris are making this who did
the old generation versions of ghost
recon advanced warfighter i think that
was around the same time that they
acquired red storm who made like the the
proper graw uh experiences but they
worked on that sort of stuff redstorm
aren't involved in this they're actually
working with ubisoft massive on the
division um but yeah as we're seeing
from the gameplay here
it seems to be and you have to be super
careful here because this is all pre
you know this isn't this is
representative of the final product
which has gotten ubisoft into trouble
with watch dogs and you could say the
division sort of feels a little bit
different as well but what we have
learned from it is that you can go in
all guns blazing you can use sniper
rifles you can use stealth you can level
up your character there's an element of
customization and there's stuff like
friendly or hostile npcs in the world
that you can get into conversations with
and apparently that's going to like
change your stake within the wider world
um and then the other thing and this is
sort of
i feel like a lot of games are trying to
throw their hat in on the co-op side of
things and then there are folks like me
who are loners who prefer to play games
on my own like i love the fallout in the
witcher milk or solid they're games that
you play on your own uh this game you
can play on your own the division
apparently you can also play on your own
but all we have received in these games
when they're showing them off and we saw
with wildlands when they showed it to e3
and we've seen it with every
division piece of gameplay as well is is
co-op experiences uh why do you think
that is my are you interested in co-op
games
does that turn you off or does it
actually make it more interesting
because i guess there's big money in
games like destiny right yeah it's not
my preferred way to play uh speaking of
co-op it's i i also prefer single player
experiences but i really do like um when
things can take co-op and make it
something special like left 4 dead or
you know like i like destiny's co-op
features but
that's what the thing about wildlands
seems like i'm hoping it's what pete
said it's more of a the tactical side of
things you can go and you know the
trailer showed going in with the jeep
and everybody just firing off rounds
then the stealthy one was kind of just
having a sniper train on the main guy
they were trying to extract and
everybody going in stealthily but what i
think they might end up going for and
what it appears they're gonna go for is
more of a cooperative third person far
cry right because
far cry itself the way they describe the
open meta world of uh wildlands is kind
of
more um they said there would be like
outposts from what i believe like this
might have changed since e3 but it'd be
more you know like kind of commanding
certain parts of the map and then
teaming up with people and then kind of
you know clearing it out and then
finding new missions around the world
yeah i mean that sounds like ubisoft the
formula right that sounds like the
structure they try to test yeah and i'm
hoping they go with like what pete said
because that was the main draw of
uh ghost recon games to me i really
liked the tactical side of things and
the co-op really worked out with those i
actually really liked feature soldier um
yeah my favorite thing but it was i
thought they nailed like especially in
the campaign the co-op campaign they
nailed that kind of teamwork so i hope
that's what they go for as opposed to
the division which seems you know rpg
focused more of these that's mmo and
that kind of seems like why people are
disappointed as well a little bit is
because they thought that the division
was going to be a little bit more
nuanced that way but it seems like it's
a
just a cover shooter like a basic cover
shooter and the thing that got me
excited about the division was the
setting you know i mean the fact that
it's in new york city it's winter i love
snow a lot of people love snow um and it
was dealing with an outbreak that sort
of caused this hysteria
um but when you're describing like the
laundry list of features that they're
going for with wildlands i kept thinking
to myself like
i like you could apply that list to so
many games over the past five years and
maybe just take one feature out and
switch it with another i just i can't
get really excited about
these games and maybe that's just me
because it's not really my thing it's
not my taste
but i just i don't know like the
division seems to offer so much more in
terms of an interesting world than
something
like
like wildlands i mean is is the the
functional gameplay aspect of it the
little things it's bringing to the table
that interesting to get back into
experience that on the surface level to
me seems so
predictable and like other games like
what is really differentiating this is
it just that it's new and that they add
in one other feature that maybe the last
game like it didn't have is that it or
is it that it's a co-op experience the
thing about that's just it like is is
co-op enough for them to spend millions
of dollars i mean it was for the crew
right like that was basically
a
driving game like so many other driving
games i know right like i i it tried
something at least with the maps but
like that's what it was right it was it
was open world yeah and it was co-op
yeah and that was basically and you
could actually say the same thing about
far cry 4 far cry 4 also big open worlds
bases all that stuff like that's what
far cry 3 was far cry 4 also had golf
like did did i i played crap at a far
cry 4. did any of you do co-op in that
game at all yeah
you didn't do you'd give it a go yeah
cause then you could do like the uh what
they call the vertibirds or whatever oh
that's like resistance yeah i don't know
you could you could use those vertebrae
yeah
yeah yeah i'm getting everything mixed
up now uh you can do like the person one
person the grenade launcher going over
the base but those were
like
the cordoned off instances where you
could do co-op right you couldn't do
that in the whole
could you know i thought you
could there was like a certain actual
what's his like huck his missions were
only right okay yeah yeah so far cry 3
had a co-op uh mode which was instant
right that was more of like a linear
shooter yes that was kind of a
disappointment but yeah far cry 4 you
know incorporated it pretty well because
that's i know for a while that's what i
was hoping for from a game was to have
open world co-op where it wasn't like
sectioned off into its own thing and far
cry did that well but i don't know that
it's as enticing as it used to be i'm
really interested to hear what folks
have to think about this actually if
they're if there's one or the other that
they're kind of looking forward to uh
while i sort of throw that out there
can you release both these games the
same year
because they seem like they're doing
similar even if like peter what you're
saying was the contemporary setting of
the division was definitely something
that sets it apart from other games it's
probably one of the most notable uh
differences uh the new ghost recon game
also said in sort of contemporary times
it's not future like future soldier
right but it's set you know in a sort of
a tropical you know bolivia it's you
know it's it's interesting in its own
way as well looks different uh can you
release these two games in the same year
considering they're both essentially
third-person co-op shooters coming out
of the same company like different
studios but you know it's not all that
different but the the themes the
thematic things that sort of define the
world might uh speak to a certain
demographic you know where the ghost
recon is sort of going for that military
feel so people who actually like that
stuff will say yeah the division fine
but military [ __ ] that's where i'm at
like it's more legit yeah i mean i feel
like with uh with the division it's sort
of a wider gamut of who can get into it
because it is more like a slice of life
you know in this sort of fantastical
scenario versus a military covert op in
bolivia you know i think that really
speaks to a certain type of person like
i i could give a [ __ ] about what guns
they're using like oh yeah they actually
use that right some people do and that's
cool for them but i don't think they're
gonna be the same people who fawn over
the division just because the base
gameplay may have like you know
similarities yeah i think we identify
with a lot of games because of the world
they present us in the story they tell
us whether it's overt or just suggested
and those games both tell very different
stories overall so i think it's okay i i
don't know that it's going to you know
ride or die based on whether the
gameplay is similar or different than
another game right um a lot of people in
the chat saying the same thing sparks v
r red animator wildlands delay to spring
of 2017. oh sure i mean we haven't heard
about the game since e3 like knowing
ubisoft and how they tend to market
these things like that that says
something you know i mean even if it's
just that they can't afford to
maybe back to your point they can't
afford to you know confuse the market
with too much advertising around
different games or too much different
you know preview events
not so much the games are competing
because they're in the same similar
genre but because it's just we only have
the audience only has time for so many
games yeah
and we're like looking at this very much
as a snapshot of what's
you know what we know right now at the
end of january 2016 like this
conversation a month ago would have been
so different this conversation six
months ago have been different so i
guess last question on this i kind of
want to
gauge interest in in your guys if you
had to pick one of these games right now
because this is kind of something i want
to revisit maybe in the future uh which
one is are you more interested in and
for what reason mike first of all oh
yeah ever since the e3 last year i've
been really interested in wildlands i
think that would have to be my pick
although we don't know a ton about it
but if they do
what they appear to do in e3 with that
tactical bent and that really more
confined like four-person kind of
gameplay as opposed to you know the
division which means more mmo-ish uh i'd
definitely have to pick wildlands
why based off beat uh for the division
for the reasons i mentioned earlier i
like the setting and the you know the
themes in the story but i also like kind
of the openness where people can
cooperate and turn on each other if they
if they want like i think that'll create
some interesting dynamics when it comes
to uh you know a group trying to succeed
or survive uh hopefully we won't have to
pick from these games hopefully both
will come out with a little bit of space
around them and they'll both be
interesting in their own ways but right
now if i had to pick probably because
i'm a massive ghost recon fan and i
enjoy the sort of being out in like open
uh i guess
not the city stuff is interesting but
i'll enjoy being out in the wilderness a
little bit you're nature boy i'm a
nature boy i play games like the long
dark and i go off and fall out and
rummage in bushes when people aren't
looking and that's what i want to do in
bolivia finally let's go to la paz and
act like a crazy weird us marine
shooting up cartel people
i don't know it seems more
it seems more interesting because of the
videos they've shown
and that's kind of what i'm worried
about is that the division more have
seen the it's like oh the glass is
coming off a little bit if they can do
something interesting with bolivia
that's kind of cool and like i know the
team went there for a few weeks to talk
to locals and figure stuff out to the
extent i don't know but i think
if they can tell an interesting story i
hate to keep beating that drum but that
can actually make me really interested
in that game because i mean i like metal
gear which has a lot of military-esque
stuff going on but i don't really like
military stuff why is that because of
you know the other stuff surrounding it
yeah devil's in the detail i guess we'll
find it soon enough uh let us know what
you think what are you looking forward
to
more if you had to pick thankfully you
don't but the division ghost recon
wildlands let us know in the comments
below which one you're looking forward
to uh which one you hope comes out in
2016. uh all right well ubisoft are not
shy on making video games of course made
a bunch of games last year people in the
chat were saying we'd the crew syndicate
what else came last year rainbow six
rainbow six siege came out on the heels
of that and we've also they've got a
game coming out pretty soon in far cry
primal we're gonna talk to you a little
about that in just a second but first of
all uh i want to get gage peter on on a
little story so we just found out that
uh
kickstarter from back in you know the
summer of what was it 2013 i think at
this stage 2012 2012
uh was uh originally it was going to
come out in april of last year its
release date was then moved forward to
mid-september and then to february 9th
and we've just found out that it's been
delayed again to earliest spring 2016 is
what yeah they're saying uh you've
talked to the dude you have sort of eyes
on this project uh from the start what
was your immediate reaction upon hearing
that because this has been a really
troubled uh project of teams for a while
yeah and keiji inafune knows it and he
and he he gets
he gets a lot of that stuff at least
based on talking to him like he
he feels bad because people are upset
but he also feels bad because they can't
relate to what he's going through as
someone who's making the game right was
trying to do something that was
you know an homage to he wouldn't agree
with this but really it's like an homage
to mega man even if it's not like mega
man in many ways but uh yeah like my
first reaction was man i feel so bad for
the guy because
one again it's another delay
two it's something like matchmaking
but online multiplayer
which you would imagine is something
that not a lot of people would have is
there like pr like we're literally just
talking about co-op like
do people care we've well we've figured
out these hurdles yeah as an industry
and i don't know that people really care
and for him to have to say or at least
be the face behind this is the reason
you're not getting the game because we
can't figure out matchmaking it's just
you know it's
for a guy like him who is all about
design these sort of like cold game
features
i can only imagine like he gives a [ __ ]
about like he really doesn't care and he
just wants to get the game out there and
make the fans happy and and you know he
said like for all the [ __ ] i'm taking
now
i know once the game comes out people's
reaction to the game will be what i
actually care about not all this stuff
and they went for nine hundred thousand
dollars on the kickstarter uh of course
it reached almost four million at three
million eight hundred and forty five
thousand and a little bit of change um
what do you think this says again about
kickstarter we've there have been
a couple of notable kickstarter problem
you know projects did not really uh they
either didn't come at it and comment in
the shape that people were expecting
them to be do you think something like
this when it's another big game and
people are looking at things like
shenmue last year like do you think that
there is less confidence or more
confidence in in the kickstarter process
especially when a big developer like
this it seems to me the general
consensus is that there's less
confidence among um the backing audience
uh but if you look at something like
money number nine it there was a lot of
hubris when they were sort of like
making stretch goals
and
like this game could have just been a
simple single player experience
and instead it kind of blew up into like
oh it's going to be on every platform
it's going to have matchmaking and all
this [ __ ]
because that's the problem right because
it kind of got too much money it i mean
yes yeah you could say that and that's
fair um and and what do you do when more
people back your project you got to kind
of like you know put that money
somewhere um
and it just you know i think the lesson
learned here is
is don't go too big unless like unless
absolutely necessary and frankly you
know i don't think that kickstarter
people need people running campaigns
need to offer more features for more
money if they if they offer something
that's a base level this is what you're
you know giving us money to make and
people want to keep giving them money to
do it okay
but don't think that you have to answer
for every like thousand or ten thousand
dollars with a new thing that's not
really going to make a difference
because your core idea is what people
are investing in yeah not these not
[ __ ] like sprinkles of new [ __ ] yeah
coffee jesus in the chat saying rather
the game be good and late and then
release before it's right i think that's
probably
not a lot of people would be as
as nice as that you know we we
anticipate games we look forward to
games coming out inafune is working on a
bunch of other projects at the moment
what do you think this says
do you then start to worry about
projects like recore for instance or any
of the other things that you sort of the
pots he's currently stirring um if you
look back to when keiji nafune started
money number nine i mean he
made this kickstarter campaign he
founded his own company in concept he
started working with integrates the team
that he's worked with in the past but
you know has now sort of charged them
with making this multi-platform game
with all these new features a thing that
they are not experienced with
so he had a lot going on by the time
this project started and you know was
seeing a lot of that through i don't
worry about recourse so much one because
it's working with a larger publisher
microsoft from the start
two armature studios is working on it as
well and that is a team that is filled
with
competent devs in context to what
they're making you know i mean they've
worked on big projects before like
metroid prime series
it's it's not out of their wheelhouse
it's like more comfortable to put it
succinctly and elegantly yes
uh peter thanks so much for uh letting
us know what you think of this obviously
stay there we need to talk to mike about
far cry but i want your thoughts on that
as well and i want your thoughts as well
on what do you think about what's going
on with mighty number nine i mean it
seems from us and the price will cover
basically any time there's a delay it
obviously is big news for us and a lot
of people like to talk about it it seems
like this is just a bad joke that keeps
on you know the punchline keeps coming
and coming to comments so if you have
any thoughts on this let us know in the
comments and if you've actually backed
the game i'd be really interested to
hear what you have to say please let us
know in the comments below uh keep an
eye on the chat actually especially for
this one i got a bunch of questions from
people via twitter beforehand but if you
have any questions about far cry primal
uh start getting them in there at daniel
dwyer on the twitch chat or on gamespot
chat mike mccarty hey you have played
the new far cry game yeah i'm excited
because far cry is a fun video game
series and i'm excited to hear about the
latest far cry game i haven't played a
far cry game none of us have since
october of 2014 well and a new one i
guess with that pagan main and all that
stuff and the helicopters and great
great fun yeah all around great fun ride
elephants and
ride elephants yeah who need why do you
need anything more
let's cut it off there's a feature list
right ellis you can go home right
elephant simulator done uh
new far cry game they announced this
late last year i want to know first of
all
kind of like the question a lot of
people are asking which is how much of a
ubisoft game is this is this very very
very familiar or is it actually breaking
interesting new ground
it does it's very familiar definitely
it's the far cry structure you don't
have to climb radio towers you don't no
it's my second question yeah they erased
that uh
kind of uh tedious part of the the games
uh for three and four especially um but
you do it's a it's the far cry structure
but of course you know it's back in the
stone age twelve 000 years ago it's
10 000 bc uh they really
did i just say that right ten thousand
yeah ten thousand bc i mean i'm not
going to [ __ ] check yours i'm guessing
there's this thing at the beginning the
very beginning it like counts back from
2016. but it uh it's the far cry
structure but they're doing enough
enough interesting things that like for
the four hours i played like powell's
attacking people jesus so in far cry 4
you could command that tiger when you go
to the shangri-la like dreamy sequences
they've taken that and made a whole like
progression tree out of you know the
people have seen the beastmaster
abilities and you can you can tame new
animals and they're pretty much your
co-op companions you can find a bear you
can ride them which we did we just
weren't allowed to show so that was like
tertiary stuff in far cry before how
much of this game involves actually
having to do like how much of the game
involves you just working with animals
very much working with and against uh so
it's almost like fighting other humans
unless you're near a camp of the other
tribes it's almost entirely you versus
like tigers and jaguars and panthers and
bears and uh oh oh my god
i'm waiting for it nice nice uh
you know you're it's very very focused
on hunting and gathering the way you
upgrade your skills it's kind of a new
skin almost you have the central village
that you return to okay instead of these
you know like three and four and two
were just these outposts where you had
armories and you could get supplies and
rest and everything and get new missions
uh this is all mainly focused around
your village which you're upgrading and
in order to get new skills you have
these specialists these characters
you're recruiting out in the wilderness
okay saying hey i have a safe cave come
back here yeah lone wanderer yeah
there's candy and everything i'm not
gonna eat you or have sex with you but
what would you lure them in with back
then like it wouldn't be candy [ __ ]
food man
there's a dead bear i haven't finished
yet look how hard it is to live back
then what type of specialist are these
like demolitions sniper
no one
one is like uh communications and you
can set up like like satellite relays
and stuff no i'm kidding
no there's there's a shaman who he's the
one that you one you uh you you
basically build up all these drugs yeah
in my mind and then they unlock the new
skills he governs the beastmaster tree
okay so you can get new tiers of animals
so you can you contain like a wolf at
first like d-dog kind of thing right and
then you start off with owl which like
scouts post then you get a wolf and then
you can get bears and jaguars but you
also get new attacks like you can you
scout with your owl you can later on get
an attack where he just like dive bomb
someone and pecks their face off right
and uh drop grenades as well yeah you
just dropped like beehive out poop you
know like poop that explodes
it's very metal gear he's kind of you
can scout from far away and then
send in your animal to attack and you
know it's uh it's kind of like going
stealthily with a bow so are they kind
of like you're
an extension of your cause like
obviously this is a game without guns
right so like
simeon souza says how different is it to
play without a fire mark a firearm are
there any like first person combat
mechanics or is there like are the
animals an extension of you
you're they're very much an extension of
you you point to certain people and
it'll attack them or you can tell them
to go somewhere taming them is a big
thing but they're also you know kind of
defense you have to heal them uh but you
it is very different in terms of combat
because you don't have a machine gun or
a grenade launcher to fall back on you
have bow and arrow until they mod on pc
yeah until they just make it far cry
primal
20
26 yeah uh i don't know it's a good year
yeah you get a club and okay spears so
you can either stab with the spears
which is a very direct forward attack or
throw them right that's almost always a
one-hit kill but you only have two of
them at first until you upgrade your
capacity uh so
it's a very brutal combat from i've seen
you're really just smashing people's
heads with a club and then you know when
there's a lot of moving targets the bow
and arrow is kind of harder to use and
the loop that you experienced was that
same kind of thing like okay there's
going to be like a story bit at the
start then you have your little village
and then
large open world and you can kind of go
off in any direction you want yeah you
can they say it's comparable in size to
four i don't know that i could confirm
that from what i saw it's definitely
just as dense there's a lot of it still
shows animals in the map where you can
hunt wolves and where you can hunt
jaguars but it's also you know you go
back to your village and get a mission
from this specialist that you've
recruited and they'll say go do this and
that progresses the story because there
are other tribes that you're fighting
there's like the udom which is the
cannibals okay and there's the azila
which are all like they're called the
flame walkers they use fire like a lot
the intro sequence to how you meet that
tribe is pretty gross actually but uh
it's a very the game overall is really
dark even for three and four it's really
just like
kind of brutal and grim and
you know just every this whole tribe
uses fire to fight people if that gives
you any indication of like the
brutality of like these cutscenes you're
seeing what is the uh the structure of
the village in terms of like society and
politics like are there leaders that you
have to sort of work with or
is that just sort of like implied and
they don't really touch on it no i guess
there are people like walking around and
you can make your own
dwelling you're pretty much the leader
of the trade you're takar you're the
leader of the you're rebuilding the one
yeah you're rebuilding the wenja tribe
which used to be this the one peaceful
and like they were very not anymore
spent on science if such a thing existed
back then but they were trying to like
just gather knowledge and they weren't
too war-like but you're just rebuilding
that and then uh there's not very much
of a political thing it's uh these
specialists are in huts let's upgrade
the specialists and unlock more skills
you just upgrade these huts by hunting
certain animal skins
it sounds kind of like you're going like
in far cry 4 you're like going into a
room so to that point uh rev o world
xylia man why don't people just call
themselves dave
on twitch says since the game is close
to early uh release only about a couple
of months more how does the does the
game feel rushed at all so does it feel
like a sort of a conversion mod for far
cry 4 or does it feel like its own thing
because it's it's doing a lot of
different stuff so it should feel
different but does it it feels no it
feels done it feels like its own thing
it feels polished uh it's
like i said people who are expecting
another far cry will get that but from
the four hours i played i cannot speak
to the whole game i have not played more
than four hours
uh from the four hours i played it it
feels like its own different thing that
is worth uh playing for a little while
like but again it's those games always a
big complaint a lot of people have is
the second half is just more the same
yeah could it survive without being
called far cry primal like what if it
was just called primal um like do you
think the game is strong enough to stand
on its own without these sort of ties to
a thing that people love um
yeah i think it's it could stand on its
own but obviously like having the far
cry gives you a glimpse into what you're
expecting is structurally um
yeah i don't know it had like i know a
lot of people thought it might be like a
blood dragon size thing at first but
yeah it's like 60 full-size game they
turned it around real quick i mean the
perception is sort of like hey where did
that come from
it's already out yeah totally i could
yeah i could very well see that i'm
having say okay here's a team that while
four is being finished you're gonna
start from the same framework and start
working on this and then we're gonna
bring those people over i don't know
what the actual internal things were but
i could very much see them as
simultaneous things if not soon after
that started from the same
uh foundation it's kind of refreshing
like because like the fallout 4 that was
very unique but like that was kind of
cool it came out of nowhere but they
have done it before with grow home that
was a game that ub's obviously much much
much more smaller in terms of scale uh
but that was a game that just appeared
out of nowhere like literally they were
like hey it's out go play it and it
seems like folks are interested in this
because it does have those touchstones
of um of the older far cry experiences i
guess like you got to wonder how much
longer they can do this before it starts
becoming a little bit rote and for you
did it
you know you were having you played four
hours was it yeah three hours of the
intro sequences and like how they're
teaching you everything and then a
little bit open world and then they
jumped us to a point where we had a lot
more beasts unlocked a lot more
abilities and you meet the azila tribe
and you fight them hard to say obviously
in that sort of situation did it feel
were you interested to play more did it
feel like it had like legs was was the
going in and sort of double
um what do you call those spears yeah
was the double spearing yeah
was that fun
yeah it killed that one it sold me
enough to be entered more interested
than i was before i played it right
which is which says something but um
again uh i'm kind of worried that it
won't last past
like
five six hours when i'm actually in the
open world and realize that i could be
doing this with machine guns right
because i don't know i guess time will
tell yeah we'll find out last question
saxton hotchubaca on twitter asks how
much caveman junk is in it
there's
oh she's going to see some dong
oh oh okay
yeah
trash
i didn't see any you didn't see any
there's no
no one was hanging four out of ten yeah
four to two
there's that low hanging you cut myself
off there yeah uh no i didn't see any
it's a shame dlc again mods vc full
review will have specific
count of how many
dongspot.com uh we got you covered mike
maherty thank you so much for talking to
us about far cry primal appreciate your
time let us know what you think of far
cry primal are you excited for it is it
a game uh that you're looking forward to
this year are you fan of dual far cry
games or is this one peaking your
interest on its own let us know in the
comments
below they're down there down there
they're in there
you're all right you got a nice little
oh look look what happens we're about to
talk about the witness and a
notepad comes out of nowhere brought a
accompaniment
i've been i haven't been feeling well i
can't speak too well don't worry about
it it's not because you're not feeling
well that's normal
um
no
i had another photo of that one as well
i just can't help myself
we're just having a good chin i can hear
whatever blowing caveman irish people
say
i know yeah hot coffee mod it's going to
come out and far cry the primal full
circle rap exactly um
i actually have also taken photographs
andy if you want to have a look at that
i've been uh i've been taking i've been
playing the witness this morning and
that's a huge spoiler is it once you get
later in the game yeah
oh i'm serious well
okay well most people will get that one
jonathan blow didn't make the game by
saying it's a huge spoiler people are
gonna go back to it now to double check
no i'm just i'm not son of a [ __ ]
it's the first hour of the game it can't
be that bad right that's the thing about
the witness you think something doesn't
matter and then bam then it does it
matters matters all right we're here a
small bump i found
watch a doctor jesus christ almighty
unbelievable unbelievable and we're
going to talk about the witness in a
second first of all though uh not a
little bit of a video we're just gonna
we're gonna like break we're gonna split
up each section by talking about some
dumb ass video game release [ __ ]
that happened before each one a little
bit of news here uh scott corthorn of
course is the guy who made five nights
at freddy's a franchise that had not won
but two releases last year
and two the previous year as well uh
he's pulled the latest game five nights
at freddy's world which you called five
nights at freddy's party in the
beginning which i did i really thought
it was cute that's a way better name
do that change it with like mario as
well yeah everybody doing this on their
joystick you're terrible you never did
that waxana wax off he's pulled it amid
kern's concerns over quality uh about uh
how much work
was left to do to finish the game uh
peter brown you had a freelance reviewer
working on this game feverishly you
didn't know it was consoled until you
saw it on today's running order uh what
is your what is your take on that on
this game getting pulled uh so
i think like a month ago uh the
developer said hey i'm gonna release
this game in two months
four weeks go by and he's like i lied
it's out now
and people reacted negatively because in
the past he had shown the game with sort
of like a fully realized um like world
map yeah um you know and but then there
were things missing from the main game
like you'd get special abilities to use
in battle you had no idea what they did
just what they were called
um and so a lot of things like that were
missing and i think this is a guy who
has found success making games that are
really simple he kind of just turns them
out not to belittle the work that goes
into these because it's a lot of work
still but at the same time he has
i don't even know if it's the audacity
the naivety to sort of gumption the
gumption
there's he's a bit he's a bit naive to
think that he can just release this game
and survive on the popularity of the
series and thinking that people won't
notice but i do give him credit for one
acknowledging that he made a mistake to
acknowledging the game needs work three
uh asking valve to
give people refunds yeah regardless of
how much time they'd spent as well
exactly um even if they liked it he said
request a refund and he said he'll give
it away for free down the road yeah i'm
super skeptical if he's even gonna go
back and put all the work into this
thing or just call it a wash it's so
strange because this game also had like
87 percent on
steam but that that that speaks to the
audience behind this who just eats up
everything this guy puts out
it kind of seems like it's a joke though
like it seems like an in joke it seems
like these don't get it man right like
because like i know look mary plays
these games a bunch in the office right
she probably plays them more than anyone
else does um on a bunch of live streams
and like
you can see that there is
it's an interesting sort of
universe if you were if you're into that
if you're i can see i can see it there's
like four versions of most of the main
cast right because he ran out of ideas
and just decided like i'll just make him
look like a ghost but if he's pitching
these games that like what's what it
seems to be is like a younger audience
right like teenagers and younger
teenagers who like a little bit of a
scare and mid 30 year old people who
stream games i guess yeah yeah exactly
like mid 30s
not married but
yeah but folks like that i'm out of
touch but it's it seems like okay he's
like putting these games out one by one
this game almost seemed like a kind of
an in joke where like hey [ __ ] it i'm
going to make an rpg edit this whole
series as well but it's just it's such a
bizarre like it feels like this is just
an internet joke that i'm not in on
maybe this is frog fractions too exactly
right so okay exactly that's my that's
that's a an internet joke i can get
behind it's it's so strange um i guess
the fact that he's going to release it
apparently for free on gamejolt after
the fact is is something to to that's
that's cool for these fans of the series
he says i'm still going to work out five
nights at freddy world and polish it up
i'm busy creating a fully 3d overworld
for the game and when i'm ready to
update the game i'll replace the demo
currently on gamejolt with the full game
from this point forward the game will
always be free i appreciate your support
and encourage you to all to refund your
steam game even if you enjoy the game
and download the new version when it
comes available on gamejolt
i don't know
uh
i guess i could probably have nothing
else to say about it
are we going to have a review of the
game actually that's what i want to ask
that's what i want to ask well we can't
publish a review right now because you
can't buy it so there's no point but
when it comes out for free on gamejolt
because you don't technically we don't
really review forget we don't review
free games yeah whatever rocket league
was free we can write a feature about it
we can talk about you know this that and
the other um
and it's not that like you it's
impossible to review a game that doesn't
cost anything or that we only review
games to inform purchasing decisions but
when a game is free the only thing
you're really risking by trying it out
is a little bit of time right so
and your time is worth nothing to
us peter's got nothing i got i don't
know what do you want me to say i don't
know we all waste time doing a name
[ __ ] all the time anyway if you
waste an hour on a bad game i don't
there you go i spent an hour playing a
really good game this morning
can you guess who it is tetris
not dissimilar apparently
okay we have to talk about this game
right we're not going to have any
spoilers no we're not going to have it's
kind of impossible well i don't know oh
yeah that's how the whole process of
trying to figure out how to like explain
certain things in the review and talk
about them was weird mine yeah was that
was that a struggle
yeah i mean it wasn't like
it wasn't it wasn't too bad it was just
they there was like a list of things we
weren't supposed to talk about which i
was i looked through i was like oh those
all make sense those are big revelations
i came to on my own but that was like
how do i explain why certain puzzles
well how do i explain how this game is
good without talking about specific
things that it does well it's all like
overarching things because there's so
many great overarching things that
witness does they're also small details
it does really well too all right let's
get into it uh jonathan blue creator of
2008's breakthrough indie hit uh brave
was also featured in indie game the
movie great movie you guys seen it yeah
it's pretty good wonderful documentary
yeah he's one of
he is one-third of the people involved
in that some of which have gone on to
release a second game some of which
haven't um he's finally released his new
game it took a couple of years it's out
it's called the witness uh it's out
today and as a massive fan of john's
work i was very interested to play it i
played a little bit this morning and
really enjoyed it mike you enjoyed it
quite a lot nine out of ten on
gamespot.com uh for folks who don't know
what the witness is you've only seen
screenshots or think uh who cares it's a
puzzle game what is it about the witness
that uh garnered nine out of ten square
what makes it so interesting yeah so
you're just you're on this weird
mysterious kind of island and it pretty
much it's just composed of these every
but like a lot of biomes from earth
there's like this autumnal forest
there's like a snowy mountain there's a
desert and you don't know why you're
there you don't know what the purpose of
the island is but it's really weird the
first thing you see is this panel and
you just click your cursor on it drag
this glowing line through like a line to
the end
press x and it opens you go through and
it's a little more complicated and that
i mean it's just a line that turns so
it's a right angle and throughout the
game you're going through these more
increasingly they become mazes and
you're just on these panels and they're
going through these increasingly complex
mazes
and like mazes you play as a child that
you'll be in like your activity book
right when you like start from one point
and how do you get to the middle but
they just sort of keep evolving yeah and
it's an open island so you can go
wherever you want right away so if you
go right toward this village in the
middle and you see these really
complicated puzzles you'll have no idea
what the [ __ ] to do at all i mean you
theoretically there's probably like a
one in ten thousand chance you can get
lucky and do the right path but odds are
that won't happen but if you go to
certain other areas it's really one of
the better uses of open world structure
i can think of in like recent memory uh
because it's it's a really hard game
it's challenging uh you can open any of
these solve any of these puzzles from
the get go it's just you're pretty much
going around the island and acquiring
the knowledge necessary there's no
hidden keys like it sounds really trite
and annoying and cliche but like you
know
the knowledge is the key like you have
to learn how to do certain things in
order to progress and there are certain
symbols in the mazes and it's it's crazy
how well the game keeps you invested in
learning the new rules because it seems
boring at first like a lot of people are
saying that's the thing
exactly like we're looking at this
gameplay you don't have like the sort of
you know the people watching don't know
anything about what any of this stuff
means like we're just drawing around
boxes and stuff like that i was playing
this morning i think the easiest sort of
thing to to combine into is i remember
playing brave and like you'd see video
of like the later levels in braid and be
like what the hell is going on like he's
moving and then the thing is moving and
then he picks up the key with his shadow
version and he's got it just looks crazy
but if there's one thing jonathan blow
really achieved at that game is that he
managed to communicate these incredibly
complex mechanics really well and in the
first
like whatever hour and a half i played
at this game there are puzzles that i
had seen in those trailers and that i
that i got stuck at while i was playing
that now they make complete sense and in
a weird way they sort of attack they're
sort of like they're familiar in a
strange way where like they feel like
you know you're walking in the street
and you're like trying not to step on
the cracks you know when you're like
you're maybe driving down the the road
and you sort of make i see this thing
where i squeeze my toes when when cars
came down against me in the traffic i'd
squeeze my toes whenever there was a car
passing and then i wouldn't i'd release
my toes like these things that they feel
like subconscious games that we always
play like in a weird way these games are
those and they're so satisfying when you
like when you solve them yeah i used to
have like really bad um manifestations
of ocd when i was younger with light
switches and certain patterns i would do
i was like clicking my tongue when i was
just sitting there yeah there's a lot of
these things i'm sure there's a ton of
theories that people are going to dig
into like what does this symbol
represent because you know you could
talk about any story present in the game
later without spoiling it but yeah
there's like you'll immediately learn
the one he showed in a lot of his in his
demos at like e3 or gdc had those
surprise demos he did uh you know you
see these white and black blocks and
it'll start off i guess it's the
equivalent of a tutorial you'll do the
first panel it's really simple just one
line directly through the black and
white box the next one there's two white
boxes and one black and you kind of
figure out
half the game and the fun of the game is
figuring out what it's telling you yeah
and the easy part is uh like applying
those skills it's really just figuring
out how what it's telling you because
like you know you talk to other people
and you're like what does this symbol
mean i still can't figure it out like
there's a flux capacitor symbol that
shows up later that's my favorite one
again i won't go into it but i was
talking to brad at giant oh my god
what's going on over here yeah we've
been talking about uh certain like how
to do certain puzzles and then uh it's
crazy how we're like did you figure this
one out yet or did you kind of figure
out what that meant or what that was
telling you it's really it's really fun
talking to other people and i walked by
your screen today yeah and you were on
one and it's funny because looking back
it's you don't really remember the
specific path you really have to be in
the moment and know what the last puzzle
you did was i was complete i did not
know what to do in that puzzle at all
when you were over near me and then like
i just got it yeah like i just looked at
the space there there's also an element
of
you sort of there's exposition happening
in the world without getting it to do
does it look like yeah they that talks
about things like you know metaphysics
and science and faith and stuff and i
came across one of those i just happened
and then it like it was this late this
i heard
basically some stuff about
faith and about god and how god both is
invisible and not visible depending on
how you're thinking about it and that
made me solve the puzzle yeah like it
was it sounds it sounds to hear you say
that and like a lot of when you're
actually listening to them they sound
really preachy and you know the yeah the
initial thing is
to say you know
indie devs man yeah like jonathan blow
doing this thing again but it's really
it's great how the game
it doesn't hold your hand at all it
communicates everything really subtly
and it trusts that you are patient and
intelligent and you're willing to
try to
read into everything possible because
there are clues everywhere they're clues
in the island there are clues in the way
it tells its story there are clues in
the way
you know certain puzzles progress and
it's it's that was one of my favorite
things is how
how it communicates so much but actually
tells you very little directly
i want to kind of ask a couple of
questions that are going to be a little
bit more
boring and mechanical okay but i feel
like there's a lot of people have sort
of on twitter as well it feels like a
lot of people who are like not sure if
they want to buy this because it's a
puzzle game and probably because of the
price tag as well it's a 40 game uh it's
he i i still feel like people are a
little bit reticent to to jump in on
something like this when it's so
abstract so just get some stuff out of
the way how hard is this game was it did
it feel safe hard like were you stuck on
a puzzle for really long and did it kill
you or was it was the payoff worth it
like what's the difficulty like in the
witness it's very very very challenging
um but that is i don't this might turn
some people off but that is part of the
charm not charm that's part of the
actual overall experience because it's
very much a game you could come back to
the next day and you'll see something
that you got stuck up on for like 60
minutes or some other people i talked to
played it
kept coming back to the same puzzle
throughout their whole playthrough and
couldn't figure it out and i had that
same one it was
it was one of the earlier ones i
couldn't figure out it was like the last
in the sequence of a new rule set you
had to learn right and i could not
figure it out forever and then i kept
talking to someone who figured i was
like do not tell me but it's killing me
and i finally and i progressed a lot
through the rest of the game and that
was the one thing i needed to
do this other big thing i was like i i'm
gonna have to ask somebody but then i
was like no you know what and then i saw
one little thing i was like are you
kidding me this last 20 hours that's
what i was missing and
it sounds like it's frustrating it does
get frustrating a lot it's mentally
exhausting game there's no doubt about
that at all for me it was but if you
stick through it and really just trust
that you can go across the island and
use that open-world structure to drop
one thing
go over to the desert if you can't
figure things out on the beach there
will be something in the desert or in
the forest or in the castle that dude
that's like some tips that's like a
motivational poster like go off to the
desert if you can't figure out the beach
just smoke this place no not encouraging
smoking
but that's that's what the moment felt
like as well for me does it is i would
have because i only i played it for sure
my time but it felt very much like dude
i want to be playing this in a dark room
on my own for like six like it felt like
it was enveloping me in this experience
is that what did it feel like that
thread throughout the game it's i was
talking to other people that played it
it's one of those games i it's been a
long time since i hate using like
hyperbole in any sense when i'm talking
about like how much i think about a game
because you know a lot i think it can
become kind of cliche to say i thought
about this game for weeks after i
finished it that's that's cool if a game
can do that but i i visually have said
that and meant it did you think
no but like you you'll start it's just
one of those things like if you're if
you're writing something long or if
you're like a musician and you're trying
to
write like what doesn't tell you like
you're writing a song or something and
you're it's kind of even when you're not
doing you're thinking about it like this
game is one of those things where
i would still think about how i could
use this symbol in conjunction with this
even when i didn't want to think about
it it wasn't like i need to get back to
the game it was more just like it
it kind of just challenges how you think
when you step back into it because it is
very very challenging but and i love
difficult games i love like miyazaki's
games i love like the old school i still
play the old school mega man sometimes
not that those are hard in the same
sense but this is really really
one of the more rewarding games i've
ever like beaten and beating it is a
weird
term i mentioned this in the review
because
there are a lot of different ways it can
kind of unfold and he said that you can
spend 90 hours playing this game which
that's another cool thing you you play
for about five hours and you're like i
don't see how this could last 90 hours
and then you find this one layer of the
game itself structurally you're like oh
my god that's another 20 hours right
there and then like you finish you get
farther in there like 90 though and you
see one more thing you're like oh my god
that i had no idea that happened it
completely it keeps changing how you see
the game as a whole which is a really
cool thing
so every time you see something smaller
like that's probably a huge deal that i
don't even want to try to wrap my brain
around right now because i'm still
trying to figure out this whole thing
which somehow connects to this
but yeah it's just the more you have
these revelations on so many different
levels as you're playing through it and
it's
it's a it's a really cool experience as
a whole but also in its detail did you
ever play fez yeah really yeah and uh
that's actually uh something else that
i had been telling a few people i was
like don't think of it as braid think of
it more as a fez um not like because you
know fez you're like has its own
language you translate if you really
want to get into it
this i guess this whole game is doing
that but on a very i think this does a
better job of communicating those fez
some of those things were really opaque
it seems like i feel like in 2016 all of
fez hasn't been uncovered yet it sounds
like one of those things you keep
hearing every couple of months oh we
just figured out this other thing yeah
just as a sidebar we don't talk about
fez enough i think that game right it's
brilliant yeah even if phil fish
maybe should keep his mouth shut for his
his own good i don't mind him but
man that game was special yeah and i and
i get the same thing that you're telling
me from the witness yeah it's hard for
me to sit here you were asking me
earlier am i going to play and i was
like i'm going to find the time you know
it's like
i have to like all right oh yeah it's
it's a very i think it's an important
game for a few reasons which you can get
into in another conversation but yeah
it's very much like fez in that the 40
price tag is completely like spend 40 in
this game it's very well worth it it's i
think it's worth more than 40 dollars
but what kind of dlc are we winning
yeah would you see the pre-order bonus
yeah a warm fuzzy feeling
the game also am i wrong i looked at the
steam achievements and it has one or no
it has one and has one hidden one it
says one is complete the game and the
second one is something else that you
won't know unless you unlock it no
they're
with the the ps4 the default we're
playing on pc there are
um certain trophies for a company
because like again the game you start to
realize what your overarching objectives
are right and you get a trophy for each
of those at least in the version we have
yeah i have to look into that because i
wonder if steam doesn't force he might
have changed it since it released fully
because again we had like a pre-release
yeah maybe so many forces people i don't
know i'll have maybe i'll have to look
into that i got a couple of questions
here yes mr vick says uh can you ask
mike how hard that one puzzle was that
supposedly only one percent of players
can pass so here's the thing i don't
know which one he's talking about
because there are three
well okay so i think there are something
like 650 or 700 total puzzles right when
i beat the game i got the soft ending as
i called it i sold about 400.
so there are a bunch that i haven't
solved
the one that i think he's talking about
it's not even that it looks hard when
you first look at it but the more you
try it the more you realize how many
like permutations are preventing you
from solving it and there are certain
rules to it that i still
don't exactly know and there's this one
series of puzzles that
uh i love watching people
or the two people i've watched after i
figured it out but it just it makes you
think about every single other puzzle on
the island differently
yeah it's like i was watching you today
and if i was like if he knows this thing
these would be so easy right now but
it's uh i hit if it's the puzzle i think
it is i don't see myself ever
finishing it oh my goodness uh all right
reviews up on gamespot.com right now
nine out of ten yeah uh uh ds park hd
makes a good point can't wait to see
soldier boy's review oh yeah it's gonna
be great somebody
you wrote your eyes rolled back so far
they might have come out of your arse
there uh uh yeah i'm looking forward to
yeah playing more with the witness
looking forward to having people talk
about it as well yeah yeah also it
doesn't seem like the type of is it the
last point is this the type of game that
somebody could spoil by saying a
sentence because it seems like so much
of the spoilers no are very abstract so
should people be worried about being in
comments or no so when i say there's a
story it's it's just
the themes it's telling there's no
there's not from what i've seen there's
not like a narrative payoff right uh so
no i couldn't spoil it i could spoil
like how to do certain puzzles but even
then it wouldn't really affect it
because you don't like open a door and
then
kaiser jose's there yeah
this just becomes frog fractions
exactly there you go uh all right thanks
mike maherty thank you so much for
coming in telling us all about the
witness and let us know if you're
excited are you excited for the witness
uh does the 40 dollars play a part um in
your purchasing decision uh do you like
hard games hard puzzle games uh let us
know in the comment box below all right
gentlemen that's a that's a lobby this
week we've only got one more week left
in this uh spot we're going to be
heading over to the studio uh pretty
quickly after that we just need a couple
of days to light it and get it all set
up i know mr bauman here is gonna be off
shooting the new intro uh with gerk
tomorrow uh we'll give you a little bit
of a sneak peek as to what this studio
is gonna look like next week uh the
builders are in this weekend so that
should be pretty fun uh before we go
though gentlemen
i'm a dictator and i say what we're
going to talk every week and it's very
mean me and a group of group of shadow
council of other um other folks uh is
there anything you guys have been
playing uh over the weekend or something
that you kind of want to you want to
highlight peter last time we had you in
you'd watched a bunch of anime yeah uh
you played any games this weekend uh
this last weekend i played gravity rush
remastered on ps4 and it was a game that
i played a little bit of on veda but i
kind of walked away from just because it
didn't grab me but
oh man this game is actually really
[ __ ] cool um manipulating gravity
like you're not flying you're falling
like doing all that is really fun and
the concept is great and on the ps4 it
looks really good and the larger format
helps you just
get into that world and feel that sense
of awe
i saw andy calling the video it looks
gorgeous it's really good it's it's a
shame because the combat is like very
rote um the missions are a bit bland but
it's got some really good characters a
setting that i like um and just like i
hate to say unique ever but but a pretty
unique way of controlling a character
and um
i think if
you know if you didn't play this game on
the vita or if you don't own a vita like
you should get it on ps4 it's it's
it's so different that i think everyone
should at least try it yeah review on
the slide yeah seven out of ten it's
actually it's a good game with problems
um and there's a sequel coming this year
awesome mike what about yourself have
you been playing or we've talked to you
probably about all the games i've been
playing uh i got back into diablo 3 over
the weekend without watching okay yeah i
played i was playing on console because
i have a few friends that just got it on
console because i've been playing on pc
most of time
and i'm reviewing
i'm just taking a look at rise of the
tomb raider on pc which releases
thursday our release will our review
will also we're just going to update our
xbox one review with how pc is
performing yeah
comparison as well yeah and then uh
xcom2 oh viewing as well that'll go up
monday the 1st can we talk a little bit
about xcom 2 because i think i'm a big
xcom fan you're a big excellent fan and
he's a big xcom fan yeah we've been walk
out
we've been covering the game uh on
gamespot for like whatever like six
months we me and i did a series with
jake solomon where we went and
interviewed a member of the game you've
done previews and stuff i just for a
second because we don't talk about this
stuff because it's sort of inside
baseball but the interesting thing about
xcom 2 is that that's that stuff isn't
trafficking people aren't keeping an eye
on xcom 2. so i'm wondering
do you think people just
feel that they know what xcom 2 is that
x-com fans trust that they're going to
fair access are going to make a game or
do you think that people aren't
interested in next come too because some
other because as somebody like we're
passionate about this these games and we
make a we make something about it and
we're excited about the game we want
people to like get excited with us but
like we could have talked about xcom
again this weekend but we didn't because
it was like oh we've done all those
features nobody really cares about it
right yeah what so what do you what do
you think do you think people don't get
are apathetic or do you think people
just know hey it's fair axes they got it
yeah it seems like one of those formulas
where you look at enemy unknown and
enemy within which is a good expansion
but you think what more can they do with
that and uh i think maybe that might be
the case which
you know
with the prequel or sorry the preview we
did was like this is a sequel it's not
an expansion it's very much doing new
things
structurally and just in the detail but
also yeah i think people probably like i
don't remember the last time frac just
released a bad game like again this
isn't me saying my opinion about xcom 2
but don't you dare review the game on
this show
i'll give it a score right here i'm just
kidding
what is it when is the review out
actually monday morning oh wow yeah
pretty close uh yeah because it releases
what the next day second
yeah yeah uh yeah i don't i honestly i
think it might just be one of those
things that it's been out of the
spotlight for a while and they don't
it's not a game that gets
as much you know like
hype or anything or like
multi-million dollar marketing campaigns
so maybe that's why it's not in the
general public consciousness right now
but
yeah we'll see what other outlets think
come monday yeah it's interesting
because i think a lot of people think
it's very similar but from playing it
it's like they're doing something yeah
this is this is no different
yeah like i mean the fundamentals are
the same but it's funny some of the
folks in the chat yes tron 23 we know
dude and we're buying and master the
hero says i can't f and wait for xcom 2.
most people seem pretty hyped about xcom
too yeah and a couple of folks uh you
know sort of wondering if you'll throw
out the score right now so we should
probably
wrap it up oh you know what i played
over the weekend apart from
uh a lot of rocket league because we're
doing our rocket league
brackets our internal tournament if you
want to watch any of the highlights for
that there's like four days i think
tomorrow streaming we've got more
tomorrow yeah tomorrow's my next match
who are you playing it's mean julio
against edmund tran it's not you and
julio me and marco sorry i'm with
me and marco are playing edmund tran in
australia oh okay and uh
oh his friends i believe what time did
you go for
six o'clock pacific so that's like
morning time there
it's their lunch break there according
to edmond all right i don't understand
who knows who knows where they are yeah
thanks for dwight all uk folks for
watching it's all just gone 11 o'clock
so appreciate you you tuned in all
ireland as well god i almost did that
thing where i only called at the uk and
ireland you know what i played over the
weekend though it was fun octodad
i'd never played it yeah i tried i
didn't i couldn't yeah yeah i found the
humor and like the ridiculousness good
but yeah the writing was actually
really good like surprisingly good i
think the reason i enjoyed it is because
i played it with my girlfriend and we
did the whole i was controlling the left
side she was controlling the right and
it's like so [ __ ] stupid so like
don't talk about co-op that's a good
[ __ ] that's a great co-op game it's
pretty short that we we we ran through
it and like we squirmed through it
the co-op is there there's five there's
four at least that's a mistake there is
there's there's one with each with each
tentacle i think it's four because what
better use of
eight player co-op
what if they're all dads
like that their kids are all sleeping
they're having a guy tonight let's play
octodad or just just just just one of
them just starts taking us no never mind
whoa sorry whoa why'd you always gotta
bring in a dark place even andy's
shaking his head no no no no that'd be a
cool use of a player co-op it's pretty
good
and dad it's a pretty good job it's fun
it was relatively cheap i feel like i
don't think it cost like 14 bucks or
something and it was good it was only
about three hours long and there was a
couple of other apparently i think
there's like steam workshop support or
something i enjoyed that it looks like
gang beasts at a glance like the draw of
like
i can't wait to see the new guy so new
gambies came in and people people are
freaking out because they've i think
they upgraded to the latest version
unity and it sort of tweaked the
fundamentals a little bit why are we
playing game beast right now i know we
have a new friday show we're going to be
doing actually once the set's built uh
and cynthia was saying we should
probably play some some hot gang beasts
on that uh all right i think that's it
uh last thing actually do you guys have
what's going on the website between
and now and the end of the week any any
big stuff that's not under embargo xcom
review monday it sounds like yeah monday
morning we've been episoded a point on
friday i can run down a list of reviews
and give you quick little snippets of
what these games are sure okay hard west
is sort of like a old-school x-com
strategy titles set in like a
fantastical dark gothic version of the
old west we got our view for that going
up mean greens is a multiplayer shooter
where you play as army men kind of we've
seen that before
tharsus is a space simulation game where
you try to survive on a spaceship but
everything you do is handled by random
number generation therefore it can be
really unfair at times but also really
fun when you succeed uh also i wish i
could do this like faster you know like
it's great yeah this is actually really
important uh
which is the game that kevin van orde
the man who handed the i don't want to
say the crown but
the shoes the boo the underwear the
crown
the burden the burden of being reviews
editor there you go to you yeah uh he
worked on that game a little bit it's a
mmo from korea and uh that will be on
the site soon uh we also are gonna have
review first uh super mario paper jam
uh i know there's more uh
monday okay on two months this week we
have the witness today pretty much all
these i'm saying are this week okay uh
this were mine the little ones oh yes
yeah what is that this wore mine i liked
but what what's the little ones isn't it
children it introduces children i think
there are a couple missions i mean
essentially it introduces an element
where it's like hey maybe in the past
you know version of the game you were an
adult and you could like take care of
your [ __ ]
you got a kid who doesn't know what the
hell is going on and they try to take
care of their children okay
um cool there's some other games right
is that tomb raider pc
oh yeah of course that's coming in yeah
don't don't brush me off just because i
mean that hair technology might be good
enough to get it a couple more what did
i get i got nine out of ten on uh yeah
who gave that in
alexa no i gave him a nine times oh you
did yeah all right i was reviewing this
one that was my first nine are you
reviewing this one it's just an update
yeah yeah all right alexa was playing
this morning with mary so if you want to
get ready
go do it they did the dlc apparently
mary breezed through it completed in
like an hour and a half or something so
fair play that's not the sound of a
breeze
that's a howl sound of the baba yoga of
the watch the baba yaga that's what the
dlc is about
that's right
guys are stealing irish mythology now
it's a banshee my friend yeah it's a
yeah oh that would i could make a
banshee noise if you want me to do it
rain your ears do it
you heard all right can't top that
thanks so much everyone for watching uh
the show on gamespot.com and twitch.tv
forest gamespot uh we've got one more
week left in here also a lot of people
asking us for a podcast version yes we
will have a podcast version of this show
uh fingers crossed for the launch of it
on february 9th back in the studio and
thank you so much for watching uh let us
know what you think of the show of
course in the comments below and feel
free to tweet out daniel dwyer we will
be back next week on the lobby same time
tuesday 2 p.m pacific see you then
you